Donald Trump has delivered his address
to the UN General Assembly outlining his
vision for the world and that vision it
seems is currently dominated by Iran
with the president warning the
international community against
supporting what he called a dictatorship
regime Iran's leadership though did not
hesitate him punching back as RT Zelia
petrenko now reports from New York the
first punches were thrown by the two
presidents here at the UN HQ on Tuesday
Trump and rouhani speeches were only a
couple of hours apart Iran's leaders so
chaos death and destruction the United
States understanding of international
relations is after a thorium
the corrupt dictatorship in Iran enemies
of peace and the Pepa traders of war
plunder the nation's resources to enrich
themselves unlawful unilateral sanctions
in themselves constitute a form of
economic terrorism Donald Trump loathed
the Iran nuclear deal struck under his
predecessor Obama according to the US
presidents version of events the Iranian
government exploited the agreements to
dodge sanctions continued fooling its
people and expanding its toxic influence
in the region plus Donald Trump is a big
fan of sanctions on Iran Tehran is
blaming Washington for treating
agreements like rubbish they're not
rolling out coming back to their nuclear
programs as part of their measures in
response
anyway Washington is clearly on a
mission to teach Iran a lesson this week
in New York the top men in charge of the
American foreign policy their national
security advisor and the Secretary of
State are hopping from one
vent to another making open threats
against Tehran and warning anyone who
dares to deal or even talk with them we
must put pressure on the regime to rein
in its destruction and demand that Iran
act like a normal country if you cross
us our allies or our partners you harm
our citizens if you continue to lie
cheat and deceive yes there will indeed
be hell to pay
the language work continues right behind
these doors where Donald Trump is
chairing a UN Security Council meeting
on Iran on Wednesday previously a u.s.
president has only done it twice and
there's barely any doubts that mr. Trump
will be trying to convince the rest of
the world that Iran has close links with
terrorists just like in his main General
Assembly speech finance terrorism and
fund havoc and slaughter in Iran we can
them all acts of terrorism without
equivocation I think Trump is playing a
game where everyone is wrong everyone is
bad everyone is ripping America off and
only Trump and only Trump is right
really America is essentially the Empire
it controls or attempts to control a
large amount of the world when someone
when any country decides to be
independent to do something for
themselves then and if America feels
this is not right then immediately they
become you know the enemy they become
terrorists this is a threat this is a do
not oppose me as mentioned Iran will
again come under discussion at the
Security Council that will be today we
will be following all the updates on
that meanwhile though we did take to the
streets of Tehran to get reaction to
what's been said at the UN
what Trump said at the UN about
supporting the Iranian nation is a sheer
lie because if it really were so they
would not have quit the jcpoa the fact
he quit an international agreement which
the US government itself had signed
before shows that his words cannot be
trusted and we can never trust the US or
hold talks with assessing Trump's speech
any sane person even a child can
understand that is contradictory on the
one hand he puts pressure on people yet
on the other he says he supports the
Iranian nation
well this demonstrates he's a liar I
believe every negotiation with the u.s.
is needed because it will lead to the
fulfillment of our demands I think it
would be helpful if we can reach an
agreement with the US generally they
have now been friends with us and they
have never cared about Iran now will
they it seems though that oh this year
Iran has taken the place of another u.s.
enemy which claimed much of trumps
attention during last year's address the
corrupt dictatorship in Iran the
depraved regime in North Korea we cannot
allow the world's leading sponsor of
terrorism this band of criminals armed
itself with nuclear weapons to possess
the planet's most dangerous weapons it
is time for all nations to work together
to isolate the Kim regime we ask all
nations to isolate Iran regime
you